قالت خدمه الاسعاف الاسرائيليه ان
مستوطنين اثنين قتل في اطلاق نار قرب بلده
حواره جنوب مدينه نابلس شماليه اضفت
الغربيه وذكرت المصادر الاسرائيليه ان
النار اطلقت من سياره عابره باتجاه سياره
المستوطنين من مسافه قريبه جدا وتمكن منفذ
العمليه من الفرار من الموقع بينما دفع
جيش الاحتلال بتعزيزات واغلق مداخل
البلدات والقرى في المنطقه وبدا عمليه
تمشيط واسعه
وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان وزير
الدفاع يؤاف جالنت سيعقد اجتماعا بمشاركه
قاده الاجهزه الامنيه لتقييم الوضع الامني
في اعقاب عمليه اطلاق النار عند حاجز
حواره في نابلس من جهته طالبه رئيس مجلس
مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
المشارك في اجتماع العقبه بالانسحاب فورا
والعوده الى اسرائيل كما دعا داجان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى تغيير ما وصفه
بنهجها الدفاعي والانتقال الى الهجوم حسب
تعبيره